dustin and weston congratulations you
fellas have made it to the third and
final round of this competition now when
you came here we had you make japanese
bushcraft knives called nadas now we're
sending you back to your home forge just
to recreate this iconic weapon from
history you ready to see what it is tips
all right that weapon is
the zulu warax
good luck blade smiths we'll see you in
four days
good luck good luck
it's been a little bit of time in south
africa so i've seen some small versions
of this i'm planning on doing a damascus
exterior on both sides and then i'm
going to leave a adcr v2 internal core
first weld on the bill it looks like
it's going really well it's time to draw
the billet out
i'll cut it and reforge it that should
get me 57 layers of damascus
i'm gonna twist that to make a really
cool pattern
now it's time to stack it with adcr v2
so that if something happens with one of
my welds the ax still has a good strong
solid core it was a good day of forging
i'll have to definitely step it up
tomorrow to get back into it all right
that was fun
[Music]
so my goals for today are to get the axe
head roughly shaped hopefully get the
tang drawn out to where i like it and
get bevels hammered in
i start by forging out the top of the
axe as i'm drawing it out i'm hammering
bevels in
gotten about an inch and a half two and
a half more to go
i've got the zulux for where i would
like it to be it's pretty well to shape
and now it's time to address the oddly
placed tang unfortunately my opening's
just not big enough to allow me to go
back and forth so i've got to cut the
whole front of the forge out
and now we have a nice big opening to
come straight in the length of my tang
is the biggest obstacle right now it's
too skinny as well as short it's
something i want to tackle first thing
in the morning because if i can't fix it
i want to start over as soon as possible
rather than wasting any time
it's the morning of day two i'm working
on the billet game plan is to split it
and start forging out the tang i've
noticed that there's a couple cracks i'm
going to grind down through those areas
and see if they've grinded out as i get
closer to my final shape my plan for
getting the tang to attach i'm going to
cut a little notch to the length of my
tang so then we'll heat it up chisel
down push that out and dried our tang
finish our blade now it's just drawing
it out to length to make sure i meet
parameters
going into the quench i'm feeling a
little nervous
those cracks in the blade that i'd seen
earlier i think i've got them ground
down
i think we dodged a bullet on this one i
think it's looking really good
so i start today off with a problem with
my tang my tang is just way too skinny
as well as short i cut two pieces of
high carbon steel fit them up next to my
tang i weld them to make it wider and
longer
but with so much going right eventually
something's going to go wrong
my breaker blew i'll be back in one
second
i really hope this isn't a reoccurring
issue today i have a lot of work to do
when i build my quench tank and there's
a lot of welding involved to do so
my quench tank is gonna be like a trough
style i'm gonna horizontally quench it
so i'm getting ready to weld and i'm
thinking it's gonna be fine as soon as
it tries to start poof my breaker goes
out
so back and forth and back and forth so
many many trips to the breaker later i
have a finished quench tank i feel good
now i'm happy what a pain in the ass
that was man
now i've got to get it quenched
so i go into the oil and i've got this
thing quenched straight skates like
glass solid is an oak i couldn't be
happier
top of day four the game plan for today
is put the final edge on the blade and
then try to get the wood section of this
build figured out i've got a section of
osage orange that i've been working on
and i've got another section of african
ebony i'd really like to use the ebony i
think the black would work great with
the damascus best way to tell if this
handle will hold up to the judge's
testing is to test it here first
yup
just what you don't want to have happen
to your expensive beautiful piece of
ebony but uh better here than there
now it's back to the osa gorge handle
before i do the final glue up and get my
blade mounted to the axe handle i want
to get the final edge put on the blade
the convex grind i've put on this i
should have enough backing behind it to
keep the edge from having any damage if
it hits wood or bone it's looking sharp
time's up and there's nothing else i can
do to it i feel like it's going to
perform well it should be able to handle
all the tests liking it it's looking
good
the plans for today are to do some more
grinding on my axe head and i've got to
do a little bit more work to my handle
i'm going to spend a little time on the
grinder cleaning it up getting it to
where i want it to be
now the blade is 90 percent done without
an edge on it it's time to get back to
my handle
so now i'm going to do some burn work on
this handle i've never done it before so
i hope it really makes the grain pop it
definitely came out really nice
so now to finish the blade i'm gonna do
an acid edge
[Music]
i'm really stoked right now it's just
better than i could have imagined
so i put a convex edge on it something
that can withstand smashing but can also
be sharp enough to slice
awesome
your zulu warax look quite scary but
it's time to find out what kind of
lethal damage they can do to find it out
i will take your weapon delivery some
chops and slashes on this boar carcass
dustin you're up first you ready for
this let's do it
[Music]
do it
well that sir thank you sue
all right dustin let's talk about your
zulu warax
it's quite surprising that something
this light with not a lot of metal can
cut deep into this bore carcass
your blade stayed true
the handle construction is all void
enough to wear even though it tapers i
have a very good feel for it overall sir
it will kill
thank you
all right wesley your turns are you
ready yes sir
[Music]
all right wes let's talk about your zulu
war axe here what i find interesting
here is that the design of this blade
there's a sweet spot in here with a
little bit of weight so that first swing
alone cut in very deep there are no
glints or rolls on it the handle
construction is avoid enough to where i
get a good grip and i can get a good
feel on it and more importantly sir
it will kill
thank you
blade smiths welcome to the strength
test
the ammo box chop i'm gonna test the
strength and durability of your axes by
smashing them into these ammo boxes
remember this test is all about what
those boxes do to your axes and not the
other way around dustin you're up first
you ready let's do it
[Music]
well dustin i've got an obvious issue
here uh i'm looking at your grain in
here it's beautiful it's nice and
velvety tight
but
right here
there's a little dark spot which was a
crack it happened right where the join
of your tang and your blade is
and that little crack
is a stress riser and it leads to big
failure sure
all right dustin your blade has broke on
the third strike against these ammo
boxes in our strength tests now that
doesn't mean that you're out of this
competition your competitor still has to
endure the same riggers weston that
means that your blade must survive three
strikes against these ammo boxes and if
it does you'll be the new force and fire
champion taking home that check for 10
grand you guys ready for this let's do
it let's do it all right ben
all right weston how you feeling nervous
[Music]
good job thanks
well weston it held up nice job this is
a nice light axe a lot of fun to swing
with every swing i could feel that the
reverberation just had kind of jiggle
into my hands
it was singing really well done thank
you thank you
weston congratulations your blade held
up dustin that means that your blade
doesn't make the cut i'd like to invite
you to shake our hands shake your
competitor's hand and then exit the
forge
great job man thank you sir
i'm pretty bummed out i really wanted to
win this whole thing weston
congratulations bud thank you good job
but this has been one of the greatest
experiences of my life this is not the
result i wanted but at the end of the
day i'm here i'm alive i'm healthy so
i'm happy
weston congratulations you made a
beautiful zulu warax and that makes you
the forged and fire champion that's a
title that comes with a check for 10 000
come forward shake our hands my friend i
am the forged and fire champion and i
feel elated i came here to prove that i
could compete with some incredibly
talented smiths and i came out on top
it's been a blast
you